please welcome my enemy Wilfer how are
you will there's no no one's applauding
well there's no audience no well no
there's no they're so used to doing that
for talk show appearances that it's hard
to break that habit yeah do you miss the
laughter in quarantine oh my god
you know what I've trained my children
to act like a roomful of sitcom writers
that everything I say they just go yeah
but the weird thing is they're now
saying things like I wrote that wrote
that line that's mine that's mine
uh-huh I want to say you won you look
very handsome I like your hair and
Quarantine you look good your hair to
get it's a nice pretty puffy your hair I
didn't realize yeah I can get I can get
a lot of volume very quickly if it's not
maintained and I don't know there's no
reason to cut it yeah
no these are strange times to say the
least
do you have anyone in your family that
you would trust with cutting your hair
here's the thing no I would not trust
anyone to cut my hair but I kind of like
just letting it go
you know you Conan pompadour sure
classic classic classic Thanks it has
collapsed under the weight of the length
of the hair and now I'm just letting it
go you're almost unrecognizable yeah do
it without the pump yeah can you hear a
truck backing up in the background nope
oh then I probably shouldn't have called
attention to it it's incredibly loud
here at the theater we're shooting at
the Largo theater I know you've appeared
here many times I am having a whole
truckload of Omaha Steaks though
delivered to you and your crew
maybe that that maybe the truck why did
you have them delivered when you knew
we'd be interviewed that seems awkward
you know what I didn't remember exactly
I just said you know they have those
windows they said anytime from one to
four so that up to me no no I are you
doing okay I like is that your office
right there that looks like the office
that that a manager would have at a
construction site what's happening it
really does look it's funny you should
say that I am in one of those many
trailers that you'd see on a
construction site uh-huh that's what it
looks like yeah with no windows just a
weird door and bad wood paneling huh
yeah this is a little a little a little
offshoot yeah a little office here yeah
would you tell me would you be honest
with me if during this period of time
you were working at a construction
oh what's that Oh Network that's a great
movie I still got to watch network so
that's on that's that's why you have you
had a you had a small trailer built on
your property so you could watch the
movie network network and what else we
got here Oh a bootleg of a face in the
crowd
okay listen to me listen to either
there's something will I got a lot of
bootlegs there's something called
streaming you could stream all of this
[Laughter]
DVD okay well I think that's a good use
of your time to be in a small Shack
watching wolves movies in an outmoded
format I'm going to congratulate you